garrett richards is about to take on
toronto this afternoon for the fifth
time a quick double
for george springer as vlad guerrero jr
climbs in 328 32 home runs breaking ball
a high fly ball into center field
driving verdugo back now coming in
springer will tag up here's the throw
toward third base it'll be close play
he's safe
he dives in fine thrown there by verdugo
the socks are going to challenge well
vadugo made that a lot closer than i
thought it was going to be
sliding away from the tag is springer
and the question is does rafael get the
hand on him
before he gets on the bag
and he is out
yeah another assist
by verdugo in the outfield they've just
been piling him up this season yeah he's
got six out there now simeon 275 with 24
home runs
fly ball in the sun martinez out there
today and jd will put that away
outstanding defense robbie ray has
pitched great baseball for the blue jays
this season a whip
1.05 he'll challenge you with that
fastball 3-1
he takes ball four so [ __ ] is on quickly
half he has 27 homers leading the league
in rbi's with eighty-one left the middle
base hit
not many get through there these days no
one at third base there goes [ __ ] the
throw he will dive in safely and down to
second goes debra's and kiki really made
that happen he fortunately went to make
mistakes he loves to take the extra base
he's always been aggressive on the base
pass i mean i thought this might be just
the first and second play but he had no
intentions but stopping at second base
the throws off target second and third
situation the runners at second and
third for j.d it was eighth and batting
at 299. one two hard hit to short
that'll drive in a run buchet is up and
over and the red sox take a one-nothing
lead rbi number 65 for jd martinez
here's hunter renfro mention he's
batting cleanup for the first time this
season there's a drive to lafayette
that's going to get up off the green
monster oh no guriel stays with it makes
a heck of a play and the throw is
offline and curry out played it very
well i thought that ball was well off
the green monster he stayed with it and
pulls it down to retire and pro like the
ball got in just a little bit and guriel
gets back in time
finds the wall he's played here before
now he understands how to play fenway
park's green monster
pitch
popped up and playable
bright sunny day here simian out into
the outfield stays with it and makes the
catch
pretty good job by robbie ray the blue
jays have another opportunity now with a
runner at third base two down now it's
going to take a two out hit by randall
grichik who's come up with a bunch of
these right back to the pitches
marriages couldn't find it and he won't
have a play
beau beshett comes in to score and the
blue jays have tied it you know what's
uh he's upset about is your first
reaction when you throw it there's a
comebacker you want to reach for the
ball and try and make the play but if he
just gets out of the way there's a
defender standing right there because
they're in the shift that second baseman
is right behind him that would have been
an easy play for him but again your
first reaction is you want to try and
make the play that's that's just you
know human nature to make that uh stab
at the ball blue jays will take it or go
as an infield hit and they've tied it up
here in the second
in the center field verdugo backs up a
bit he's there to make the grab and
retire the side only one out here
do go to base hit to start the inning
plowecki with the double down the line
that jumped into the seats dalbeck with
the walk chavis struck out the high
fastball crowd wants to see kinky do
some damage that's the 25th pitch of the
inning fastball got it hernandez chased
a high fastball borderline pitch
upstairs and ray gets another big
strikeout so back-to-back strikeouts
for robbie ray that one he threw right
by him raviol devers had a base hit to
center field his first time up in the
air deep center field
springer has rue he is there and ray
gets out of it this kid's having a great
year he really is he's having a
tremendous year he'll bloop that one
long run chavis leaves his feet makes
the play
and guerrero is out he's over two
nice play by james you know it was not
hit all that hard it's high enough for
him to get over and make a position play
on it
he does
bouncing ball weekly hit toward third
bare handed by vizio nice play at third
kevin throws him out a do or not play
for sure and he came in very handy got a
good stretch from bloody over at first
and new grichik has an rbi already today
he is driven in the only blue jays run
and in the air in a deep center field
this ball is up and
gone over the wall in center field for
randall grizzik he stays back and clubs
it to deep center field his 19th home
run of the season and randall has driven
in all three blue jays runs
got the barrel on that one and smoked it
to center field
puji's come up with some big hits for
the bouche this year he had an infield
hit that drove in a run now this laser
to center field's going to drive in two
more so time of the order once again
george springer is one for chill he
doubled his first time up as a slow
curve ball hit hard and deep and gone
home run for george springer
he broke out the curve ball and springer
was all over it his ninth home run of
the season
maybe that's why he hasn't thrown it
that often because the blue jays do that
that home run trot
by springer slow curve ball george waits
for it to break recognizes it doesn't go
out to try and get it waits for it
and hits a bullet
to left field that's 73 home runs
they've now hit on the road that's time
for the race for the mode american
league toyo is saying you know what
you're my guy robbie ray you're strong
let's see if we can get you through the
sixth inning nice play by guriel in left
field on that sinking liner he got a
good break and takes it just before he
slides to the turf
as vernougus retired
one down that's a couple of really nice
catches by guriel in the outfield
you know you don't have to play that
deep because anything over your head's
going to go off the wall so you can take
away base hits like that
a line drive to left field got a good
jump on it robbie ray appreciates the
effort one down you're going to see a
lot of swing in this there's a change up
for a swing and a miss as kirk hangs on
to it he might have outshipped it but
the catcher held on for the strikeout
that's seven strikeouts for ray so
here's bobby dalbeck he is one of those
strikeout victims he has walked and
struck out riders swinging to miss what
a job by robbie ray
two strikeouts in the six that gives him
eight over six innings jordan has been a
perfect seven for seven in his last
seven save attempts fly ball into center
springer's got plenty of room he makes
the catch and that's the ball game
jordan romano picks up the save
for romano that's his eighth save of the
season for robbie ray his ninth win he
improves to nine and five